When I read the, um, Kurzweil's book about the singularity,
to me, it read just like, um, religious language, like it read, like,
you know, cause he, they,
in fact it's so much like revelation to me when I read it that I
even assign it to my students in my classes. I'm like, this is, this is it.
You know, this is like a really great book of the singularity, you know,
the coming singularity and um, this religious event,
because it seems like it when he writes about it, he says,
I felt it before I even understood.
No, he mean Kurzweil, Kurzweil. Yeah. Chris w I mean,
what are your feelings about feelings, thoughts, and feelings too,
about the, the idea of the singularity.
Do you think it's ultimately the thing that echoes throughout the history of
ideas is this, um,
like moment of revelation like this,
this almost mythological religious moment,
or is there something more
physical to this idea of concrete about the idea of,
um, they'll come a point where our technology there'll be like a phase shift
between, uh, um, the,
the basic fabric of like humanity, of how we interact, you know,
how evolution brought us to be these biological interaction. They,
our technology, uh,
crosses some kind of line of capability that the world would be more
technology than human to where it leaves us behind.
Oh yeah. I don't think it's going to leave us behind.
I think it's going to take us along.
But it will be, I mean, I guess they did the singularity, first of all,
it isn't they do the singularity is like,
we can't possibly predict what's on the other side of the singularity.
These are the census.
Like this is like the world will be fundamentally transformed.
Yes. Okay. So right. And then it was, you know, um,
this was characterized in various movies like Lucy and stuff like that. Uh,
you know, Lucy being the first human that right. We so kind of replicating,
this is going to be the next iteration of humans is the singularity. Um,
I actually don't believe that, um, frankly, however,
and the reason I don't believe it is because we're material beings and
technology has to have a host, so we're not gonna, you know,
become something super abstract. Like there's, it's just an impossible to do.
There's nothing like that.
What people will be listening to this podcast a hundred years from now and
laughing at it because
they'll be all existing in a virtual reality will be all information, uh,
as opposed to material,
meaning connected to some kind of concept of physical,
uh, physical reality. I don't even know the right words to use here.
See that's because there are none because there's no place from,
there's no view from nowhere. There's no non material.
Like we have thoughts, but they're connected to us right there in our, you know,
they're somehow okay.
As far as, uh, as far as, you know.
Listen, platonic forms I think is about, is, is, you know,
close to what we're talking about is possible.
Like this place where these things exist.
And then there's like a physical instantiation of it.
Uh, the question is from the perspective of the platonic form,
what does our physical world look like? You know what I'm saying? Like, um,
you know, if, if, if say you're a creature existing in a virtual reality,
like if you grew up your whole life in a
virtual reality game, like,
what is it in somebody in that virtual reality world tells you that there
actually exists this physical world. And in fact,
your own, you think you're in this virtual world, but it's actually,
you're in a body and this is just your mind putting yourself.
And there's a piece of technology, like how will they,
how will they be able to think of the physical world? Would they,
would they sound exactly like, you just sounded a minute ago saying like, well,
that's silly who cares if there's a physical world, it's the,
the entirety of the perception and my memories
and all of that is in this other realm of, um,
of like information. It's just all just information. I,
why do I need some kind of weird meat bag to contain?
There's a great again, I was re you know,
returned to something for your audience to read or you, um, there's a great,
very short article online for free by David Chalmers. Do you know him?
He's the philosopher of consciousness.
On this podcast. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. He's cool. Um, I used to,
I was friends with his best friend for a while. When, when I was in grad school.
He probably has some weird friends.
Philosopher. Okay. So, um.
I like his fashion choice in hairstyle to hang out with him,
but he's a great guy.
Okay. So he wrote this article, which I use a lot.
I love it because it's accessible to undergraduates and it's called matrix as
metaphysics. And basically it's,
it's an answer to external world skepticism,
which is basically how do we know there's an external world, right?
How do we know that we're not in a matrix right now? And so, um,
basically he's using he's, he's also,
he even references, he uses a religious reference, even he says,
you can think of the matrix,
the movie as a new, as the new, um,
book of Genesis for our new world. Right. And I thought, yeah,
that's absolutely correct. Because, you know, we don't know.
And we don't, we won't know for sure. Or for certain,
therefore what we know is what is real to us.
And so he goes through these scenarios and within philosophy is called,
there's a, it, this is different from that, but it's like this brain in a VAT,
right. If you're a brain in a VAT and some not so kind scientist is like
recreating this world for you, just to see, you know,
and you think you're this awesome rockstar. Right.
And you're living this awesome existence per actually just this brain in this
VAT. Okay. But there's still a brain in a VAT. Okay.
So his idea in, um, the matrix says,
metaphysics kind of takes out the brain in a VAT like this.
I don't know if this is possible. So I've read critiques of this, that,
you know, what you're talking about is a non-dualism like, there's like, um,
you know, or it's not necessarily a non-dualism.
Um, I just, I mean,
information in and of itself has to have some
kind of material components.
I mean, I it's that, that, that, uh,
when taking it outside of the realm of human beings,
cause dualisms kind of talking about humans. Yeah.
In a sense it's just possible to me that there could be creatures that exist
in a very different form,
perhaps rely on very different set of materials that,
that may or may perhaps not even look like materials to us. Yes.
I agree. Which is why like information, it could be,
even in computers,
that information that's traveling inside a computer is
connected to actual, um, material movement.
Right. Right. So like there is, it is ultimately connected to mature movement,
but it's less and less about the material and more and more about the
information. So I just mean that there's, it's possible that, uh.
Clarity is basically like sloughing off our material existence
because I can tell you that this has been the hope philosophers and theologians
forever.
Yeah. Well, I don't, I think we're living in a sing, uh, through a singularity.
I don't think, I think this world just, just like, as you said already,
um, has been already transformed significantly and it keeps continually being
transformed and we're just riding this big,
beautiful wave of transformation. And, uh,
that's why it's both exciting and terrifying, uh,
from a scientific perspective that like we're so bad at predicting the
future and the future is always so amazing in terms of the
things that has brought us. I mean,
I don't know if it's always will be this exciting terms of the rate of
innovation, but it seems to be increasing still as really exciting.
Yeah. It's terrifying because.
Obviously we're building better and better tools for destroying ourselves.
But I, on the optimistic side,
believed that we're also can build better and better tools to defend against
all the ways we can destroy ourselves.
And it's kind of this interesting race of innovation.